as the body count mounts in ukraine as
vladimir putin is reportedly attacking
even residential areas in his conquest
of the breadbasket of europe the
american establishment news media are
focusing on issues that really matter
like the effect of the invasion
on transgender acceptance
cbs news is reporting that quote
transgender acceptance in ukraine is not
widespread and changing legal documents
to match gender requires a long process
with psychiatric evaluations
i suspect the psychiatric evaluations go
something like this sir do you think
you're a woman no okay you pass
yes you do sorry you fail
would seem like a pretty straightforward
psychiatric examination i digress the
network goes on quote cbs news spoke
with one woman in kiev who is now
battling a war within a war amid
russia's invasion
the woman of course is a man and the war
within the war is a sexual delusion
presently being crammed down everyone's
throats by an increasingly decadent
secular west but the news report is
actually a helpful reminder to the
warmongering globalist liberals who two
weeks ago couldn't have pointed to kiev
on a map
it reminds them
ukraine is not your toy
it is not
you it's merely the area of the world
where you can superimpose your own
delusions and your own preferences
ukraine is a nation and a people with
its own beliefs
and customs and interests
and way of viewing the world
and maybe if our leaders in the west had
had even a modicum of humility and
prudence maybe if they had shown just
the teensiest tiniest bit of respect for
those national differences and for
ukraine's unique and uniquely vulnerable
place in eastern europe
perhaps we wouldn't all find ourselves
today on the brink of world war iii but
i suppose that sort of basic competence
and judgment is too much to ask of a
ruling class that can't tell the
difference between boys and girls did
you like that clip i'm so glad you know
we're entering into a penitential season
right now and and one thing that i would
recommend giving up for lent
would be all the other podcasts other
than mine
you obviously you should continue to
listen to my podcast but you could give
up all of the other ones and then you'll
have time to listen to more of my
episodes which you can get at apple
podcast spotify stitch or google play
type in the michael knoll show subscribe
leave a five star review obviously ring
the bell here we'll see you next time
[Music]
[Music]
you